bon nombre d'entre nous ont déjà lu les
aventures d'alix une bande dessinée de
jacques martin alsacien de naissance
l'auteur et dessinateur s'installe à
bruxelles en 1946 l'année de naissance
du journal tintin et le rejoindra
ensuite l'hebdomadaire et en 1948
apparaît alix pour les 70 ans du
personnage une centaine d'originaux de
jacques martin sont à découvrir à
l'espace richaud de versailles parmi les
visiteurs son fils bruno martin il a eu
le virus du dessin quand on était jeunes
parce que voilà il semble était beaucoup
il était en alsace avec son père s'était
casernés à l'époque en masse après la
guerre de suite
il a commencé à dessiner comme ça et à
se raconter des histoires
jacques martin a fait des études de
dessin est remarqué par raymond leblanc
du journal tintin il a rencontré hergé
qu'il a engagées dans son studio il a pu
travailler aux aventures du célèbre
reporter mais aussi sur sa propre bande
dessinée il aimait jouer avec les
symboliques et avait des thèmes chers
des rêves prémonitoires les rêves qui
annonçait des catastrophes
l'être humain tout petits qui va être
écrasé par sa destinée est ici la
précipitation dans le feu à la
destruction c'était toujours des images
très très dramatique très anxiogène
jacques martin dessine écrit seule la
série de 1948 à 1988 il arrive très vite
à s'emparer de son personnage
alix pour le confronter au réel il est
mis en péril
ils ne gagnent pas toujours ses combats
une doit faire face au réel il ya
quelque chose de la realpolitik dans le
travail de jacques martin son travail
est exposé à l'espace richaud 100 pièces
originales mais aussi des planches en
noir et blanc quelques dessins et des
mises en couleur originale de planches
de bandes dessinées à découvrir jusqu'au
19 avril